foreign
[Music]
I'd like to thank the organizers of lab
roots for giving me the opportunity to
share our research with you today before
I start talking about our work on
antibiotic treatment failure and
persistence I just like to acknowledge
the students who contribute it to the
experiments that I'm going to be talking
about today
so this is my group here at UConn Health
in Farmington Connecticut and today's
talk will feature experiments that were
done by Brandon Byrd blessing zenik
Travis LaGree Trish hair and Hannah
Englander I'd also like to acknowledge
the following funding agencies for their
financial support
so as many of us know antibiotic
treatment failure is imposing a heavy
burden on Public Health Systems across
the world and it is projected that this
problem is going to intensify in decades
to come and that is why my research lab
like many across the globe are
interested in understanding how bacteria
can overcome the effects of our existing
antibiotics so that we can preserve the
efficacy of our existing drug Arsenal
and also those are currently in
development
so we think about antibiotic treatment
failure we often think about it in the
context of antibiotic resistance so
resistance occurs when a bacterium in a
population acquires a heritable genetic
change that allows them to grow in the
presence of an inhibitory dose of a
given antibiotic so this change may be a
point mutation in the primary target of
the antibiotic or the bacteria May
acquire a transposal
principosable piece of DNA or extra
chromosomal piece of DNA like a plasmid
that encodes a gene that would allow to
overcome the effects of the drug
so as this resistant mutant grows and
divides then this mutant can pass these
genes onto its progeny spreading
resistance in the population
and so in the lab and in many clinical
microbiology Labs we can detect
resistance development by measuring the
minimum inhibitory concentration of a
drug for the population and so for
example one way of doing this would be
doing a broth dilution assay that's
illustrated by this cartoon here so we
can try to grow the bacterial strains in
increasing concentrations of a given
antibiotic and we can detect resistance
emergence by looking at a shift towards
higher mic compared with a wild-type
susceptible population
so population-based experiments like
these brought solution assays can tell
us a lot about the physiology of a
population so another type of these
assays that we may do routinely in the
lab is measuring the growth of a
bacterial culture like this growth curve
shown here in which we took E coli
inoculated it into a mutant Rich broth
and then monitor the change in optical
density in the culture over time and
from the experiment we might be able to
tell that the population initially
experiences a lag in growth before it
starts to grow exponentially and then it
exhaust nutrients in the population and
then it reaches stationary phase
but what these type of experiments don't
tell us is that within that genetically
clonal population there may be bacteria
that are behaving differently from one
another so it masks these phenotypic
heterogeneity that might occur in the
population so let's take this culture
again and this time instead of
inoculating it in broth we're going to
seed it on aggro's pads containing
nutrients
so I would like to draw your attention
to the two E coli cells that are
highlighted by the arrows in the image
and so over time we can monitor the
growth of the population by time lapse
microscopy
and we do this we see that many of the
cells in the population would start to
grow and divide giving rise to many
daughter cells by about the 180 minute
Mark but we see that the two cells that
I've indicated with the arrows in the
images
they are slower to grow and they hadn't
divided within this three hour time
period so it indicates that those are
slower growing phenotypic variants in
the population
so if we were to track the growth of
individual cells in the population
looking at how long it takes them to to
First divide and the length of the cells
when they first divide we see that there
is a lot of heterogeneity in the
population and is thought that
phenotypic heterogeneity in the
population whether it is differences in
how bacteria grow their metabolism and
gene expression those have been linked
to their ability to tolerate antibiotics
and so in my lab we're especially
interested in the phenomenon of
antibiotic persistence and antibiotic
persistence occurs when you see a
genetically clonal culture of bacteria
but within this population there's a
subset of bacteria that may be more
tolerant to antibiotics at doses that
may kill the genetically clonal kin so
in the lab we can detect persistence
when we take a genetically clonal
culture of bacteria and treat it with a
high dose of a bactericidal antibiotic
as we depict in panel two of this
cartoon here and we track the survivors
that remain in the culture and plot the
survival along the y-axis of this curve
on the log scale and time on a linear
scale on the x-axis we may typically see
by phasic killing as you can see in
panel 2 here so what this tells us is
that this population is phenotypically
heterogeneous and it consists of a
population that may be rapidly killed by
the drug as you can see in the first
phase of this skill curve but there is
also a sub population of cells point
persisters that may be skilled at a
slower rate or not at all
so you take the persisters that remain
at the end of this course of treatment
dilute the drug to sub mic levels and
then allow the persisters to recover and
resume growth in the presence of
nutrients
and then you take the resulting
population and treat it with the same
antibiotic again you would typically see
by basic killing again oftentimes the
slopes of the kill curve may be similar
to what you see in the original kill
curve so this indicates that the
persistrative phenotype is not heritable
and when persisters resume growth they
can grow and give rise to both
persisters and non-persisters so this is
a cartoon depiction of persistence in
the lab we certainly see persisters in a
number of different bacterial species so
in my lab we generally study persistence
in E coli pseudomonas erogenosa and also
in staphylococcus aureus but persistence
has been reported in a number of
different bacterial pathogens so if we
take a population of E coli that's
susceptible to this antibiotic which is
a fluoroquindolone called levofloxacin
this population is susceptible to the
drug and the mic is 0.023 micrograms per
Mill but if we take this culture and
allow it to grow and then treat the
population with a high dose of
levofloxacin so here we had applied five
micrograms per mL of levofloxacin so
this far exceeds a hundred times above
the mic and we track the survivors that
remain over time we see this by basic
kill curve indicating that there are
persisters in this culture
so even though the persister phenotype
is not heritable
persistence has been thought to underlie
relapsing infections and as you will see
in a few slides our group and others
have shown that persistence can
accelerate the development of antibiotic
resistance and that is why my group and
many others are interested in
understanding how persisters can
overcome the effects of our our existing
antibiotics
so in my lab we're especially interested
in understanding how persisters can
survive treatment with topoisomerase
Inhibitors and these drugs Target
topoisomerases like DNA gyraces which
can change the supercoiling state of DNA
during DNA replication transcription and
at high concentrations these drugs can
lead to DNA double-stranded breaks and
cell death
so if we treat populations of E coli
with high doses of fluoroquinolones that
is one of these topazomerase Inhibitors
so treating them with a drug like
levofloxacin we can see that they can
kill these populations and we also see
that when we treat a population that is
growing in the presence of glucose this
drug can reduce the Survival by about
three to four orders of magnitude but if
we take a population that has been
starved of glucose and so they're in a
slower or non-growing state as you can
see in the red curve there we see that
the drug can still kill about 90 of the
population but the survival and
persister levels is much higher compared
with what we had seen in the growing
culture that was in a glucose-rich
environment
so we're especially interested in
understanding how bacterial populations
that are slower and non-growing can
respond to antibiotics especially how
persisters in these cultures can survive
because these cultures are generally
more tolerant to a range of different
antibiotics that we currently have on
hand
[Music]
so
some of the questions that we set out to
ask when we first designed this project
involved include so we see that these
persisters can survive treatment with
lethal doses of these topazamarase
Inhibitors so do these persisters still
suffer from DNA damage
what defenses do these persisters depend
on to survive treatment with these
topazomerase inhibitors
and can we leverage what we learn about
how they survive existing topazamarase
Inhibitors to try to potentiate the
activity and sensitize these persisters
to new topazamarase Inhibitors that are
in clinical development
so in answer to our first question do
these persisters that can survive
topoisomerase inhibitor treatment still
suffer from DNA damage we took on a
relatively simple genetic approach in
which we deleted a gene called Rec a
which is a key player in the DNA
double-stranded break repair and also in
in orchestrating the DNA damage repair
SOS response in bacteria like E coli and
we see that in this mutant the survival
of the population was treated with
levofloxacin fluoroquinolone decreases
by about three to four orders in
magnitude compared to his wild-type
counterpart so this result suggests that
these persisters do indeed suffer from
DNA damage and they depend on record to
survive
so to look at when these persisters may
be repairing their damaged DNA we may
use of a fluorescent gene expression
reporter that reports on the expression
of brachi so in these plasma-borne
reporters the promoter of Rec a is
transcriptionally fused to a gene
encoding the green fluorescent protein
or gfp so we can transform these
plasmids into our bacteria and then look
at when fluorescence is induced to gauge
when Rec a may be induced
so first we treated a population of
slower non-growing culture of E coli
with levofloxacin and after a period of
treatment that would leave for sisters
as the sole cultural cells in the
population we diluted the effect the
antibiotics submic levels and allowed
the cells to be covered in the presence
of nutrients and we monitored the
expression of this record reporter over
time
and we did this we saw that when these
cells were first inoculated in this
antibiotic-free media containing
nutrients most the cells remain dim
and it wasn't until they had had time to
recover in this media that we see by
flow cytometry that there's a shift
toward higher fluorescence in about 90
percent of the population so this
suggests that maybe the cells were
activating wrecking expression as
they're recovering after fluoroquinolone
treatment
so to look at this further
we inoculated these cells on aggro's
pads containing nutrients as they
recovered from antibiotic treatment and
this way we can monitor these cells by
time lapse fluorescence microscopy and
consistent with our flow cytometry
histograms we see in these images that
most of these cells remain Dim when they
were first inoculated onto these agarose
pads and as they had had time to recover
in the presence of nutrients when the
drug has been diluted to submic levels
we see that the majority of cells in the
population
fluoresce and they also filament it as
you can see in the image in the 432
minute mark
and so they fluorescent filamented
regardless of whether they go on to live
or to die
and so they they form these long
filaments because one of the gene that
is part of the SOS DNA damage response
is cell a and cell a inhibits cell
division until the cells have had
adequate time to repair damaged DNA
so we also see that in these images
there is one cell that is indicated by
the red arrow that at some point around
the 468 minute mark it splits into two
and then it further divides giving rise
to a micro Colony by the 540 minute mark
and it dilutes the fluorescence as it
divides so that is an example of a
persistor
so collectively these data suggests that
in persisters originating from slow or
non-growing E coli cultures that have
been treated with fluoroquinolones these
cells still suffer from DNA damage and
they depend on DNA damage repair in the
post-antibiotic treatment recovery
period to survive treatment
so we then asked what are the defenses
do these cells depend on to survive
treatment with these fluoroquinolones
so to address this we turn to genes that
encode these multi-drug efflux pumps
including the resistance nodulation the
division family of pumps including Acra
B and Tulsi and E coli
so this work was led by a former MD PhD
student Brandon Byrd together with a
former post-bac student blessing zenik
and we decided to look at the
contributions of these pumps because for
quinolones like levofloxacin and a new
fourth generation for quinlon called
delafloxacin there are substrates of
these multi-drug efflux pumps and so if
we're to delete genes and coding
components of these pumps like deleting
acrb or told C we see that the mics of
these drugs decreased considerably
compared with the wild type counterparts
so we then asked because these drugs are
substrates of this pump how does loss of
genes encoding the pump components
affect Persistence of the mutants when
they're treated with these drugs when
they're in a slower non-growing state
and interestingly we saw that even
though levofloxacin is a substrate of
the pump loss of pump action did not
affect persistence toward levofloxacin
but on the other hand we saw that in
populations treated with delofloxacin
loss of acrb and we had also deleted
Tulsi that resulted in a decrease in
survival of about 10 to 100 folds
compared to the wild-type cells
so we then asked what happens to the
other fluoroquinolones there are also
substrates of these pumps does the loss
of pump action affect the persistence
like what we saw with delafoxin or is it
more like what we had observed with
levofloxacin
so we also treated these populations
with two other fluoroquinolones
ciprofloxacin and clinofloxacin
and in both of these treatments the
phenotype that we observed was
reminiscent of what we had seen with
populations treated with levofloxacin so
loss of pump action did not affect
persistence toward these two
fluoroquinolones
so these data indicate that loss of
efflux pump action only really affected
persistence toward delafloxacin in these
slow or non-growing populations of E
coli
so previously has been shown that
bactial persisters may use different
strategies and defenses to overcome the
effects of different classes of
antibiotics that Target distinct
cellular processes so here what we're
seeing is that perhaps for cells treated
with different compounds within the same
class of drugs depending on the compound
that is used cells may also Mount
different defenses to survive treatment
with the drug so if we look at the
structures of these different
fluoroquinolones we see that
levofloxacin ciprofloxacin and
clinofloxacin there's zwitter ionic
neutral pH whereas stellofloxacin is
anionic so it is thought that
dellofloxacin may be able to better
accumulate inside cells and that might
explain why these persisters depend on
efflux pumps to overcome the effects of
dilofloxacin
so as I had mentioned when
fluoroquinolone persisters originating
from slower non-growing cultures are
treated with the antibiotics they suffer
from DNA damage and they need to undergo
DNA damage repair after antibiotic
treatment is over to survive so here we
wanted to ask
do these stellofloxin persisters depend
on the effects of efflux pumps during
dellofloxacin treatment or once
treatment is over
so to address this we made use of a
small molecule competitor for the effex
pump called PA beta n
and so with this competitor we can
administer it either together with
delafoxin so disrupting pump action
during dellofloxacin treatment or we
would add PA beta n to the cultures
during the post-antibiotic treatment
recovery period so when stellofloxacin
has been diluted to submic levels and
cells are recovering in the presence of
nutrients
and so when we carried this out
we saw that when PA beta n is added
together with delafloxacin as you can
see in the red curves here survival of
the population decreased by about 10 to
100 folds compared with cells that were
treated with zealofoxin alone and this
is similar to what we had observed with
the genetic mutants that you had seen a
few slides ago
and when P beta n is added after
delofoxin treatment is over we saw that
the survival of the population is
comparable to cells that were treated
with Della alone as you can see in the
black and gray Curves in in the graph
so this demonstrates that these
delofoxin persisters from these slow and
non-growing populations were dependent
on e-flux pump action during de lafoxin
treatment
so previously has been shown that when
for quinolone persisters originating
from slow or non-growing cultures are
treated with the drug and then the
persisters allowed to recover in the
presence of nutrients once the drug is
removed
when you challenge the progenies of
these persisters with different
antibiotics you would detect an increase
in resistance development in the
persistent progeny compared with
populations that were not exposed to the
fluoroquinolones
and here what we had seen was that we
observed an increase in the number of
resistant mutants in the persister
progenies not only when these cells were
treated with the fluoroquinolone that
was originally added to the cultures so
ofloxacin in this case we also saw an
increase in the number of resistant
mutants in the persister progenies when
they were exposed to rifampicin which
targets RNA polymerases and also when
these progenies upper sisters were
exposed to a number of different cell
wall synthesis inhibitor like
carbonicillin d cycloserine and
fostomycin
so here we wanted to ask whether these
stellofloxacin persist your progenies
also exhibit an increase in the number
of resistant mutants in the population
and how does the disruption of these
multi-drug efflux pumps during delofoxin
treatment affect resistance development
in the persist or progenies
so first we had seen that when these
cells are exposed to dellofloxacin and
the persisters are given the opportunity
to recover from treatment we see that
there is an increase in the number of
rifampis and resistant mutants in the
persistent-derived cells similar to what
we had seen in populations that were
treated with levofloxacin another for
quinoa
and as I mentioned for levofloxacin
persisters we had seen that loss of
reflux pump action during levo treatment
to not affect persistence toward the
drug
we also saw that loss of effex pump
action by deleting acrb did not affect
resistance development in the levo
persister progeny
but we had seen that
for cells that were treated with
dellofloxacin loss of e-flux pump action
either by deleting acrb or Tulsi or
exposing the cells to PA beta n during
dalofoxin treatment that resulted in a
reduction in resistance development in
the Della persister progeny
and it wasn't until we had complimented
acrb back into the deletion mutant that
we saw an increase in the number of
resistant mutants similar to what we had
seen in the wild type population
so these data suggest that perhaps
disrupting e-flux pump action during the
lafoxin treatment could affect
resistance development in the persistent
progenies and maybe disrupting efflux
pump action during treatment could be
affecting the coordination of molecular
events during the post-antibiotic
treatment recovery period as these cells
are repairing DNA and and resuscitating
after antibiotic treatment so right now
my group is investigating this to get a
better understanding of what is going on
so from this part of the talk I hope
I've shown you that for slow or
non-growing populations of E coli that
are treated with older generations of
fluoroquinolones like levofloxacin Cipro
and clinofloxacin loss of e-flux pump
action did not affect persistence toward
these cells
so for populations treat it with
delafloxacin disruption of multi-drug
effects pumps like AC or a b and Tulsi
could decrease persistence toward
delofoxism and that could also affect
resistance development reducing
resistance development in the progenies
of these stellofloxacin persisters
so next we want to see we can take what
we had learned about some of the
defenses and vulnerabilities of these
um these for quinolone persisters to try
to sensitize slow and non-growing
populations of bacteria like E coli to
new non-floroquinolone topazamarase
inhibitors
and this work was once again led by
Brandon together with PhD student Travis
Legree and we decided to focus on Zola
floaticine which is currently in phase
three clinical trials
so because solar fluorescent is a
topoisomerase inhibitor we first asked
whether Zola photosyn like what we had
seen with fluoroquinolones whether it
can also kill slow or non-grown
populations of E coli
and the answer we got back was no so we
had applied xolophoticin at high doses
at about 100 micrograms per ml which is
about 50 times above the mic and we
didn't see an effect on the survival of
these populations
the zolophoticin is a substrate of a
serum a B tool C and so we asked how
does the loss of e-flops pump action
affect Zola flotacin do we see a
reduction survival similar to what we
had seen with zalafloxacin
and we saw that loss of acrb did not
affect persistence towards Zola photosyn
so previously it has been demonstrated
that bactro persisters and cells that
are in a slower non-growing stage they
can still retain metabolic capacity and
they can respond to metabolic
stimulation which can sensitize them to
different classes of antibiotics and
these include aminoglycosides that
Target the ribosome
fluoroquinolones and nitrofurants
so Travis and Brandon then looked at
whether they can stimulate the
metabolism of these slow and non-growing
populations of E coli with glucose and
whether that would sensitize them to
zolofloticin
and they saw that at the highest
concentration that they tested adding
glucose to stimulate the metabolism of
the cells did significantly decrease the
survival of the population but by about
10 Folds and it wasn't until we combined
the effects of metabolic stimulation
together with loss of e-flux pump action
as you can see by the purple curve that
we saw a significant decrease in
survival of these slower non-grown
populations treated with Zola fluidusin
across a range of solely concentrations
that we had tested
so this demonstrates that a spoonful of
sugar combined with a knock to the
multi-drug efflux pumps of these slow
non-growing population of bacteria could
help sensitize them to zolofloticin
so we then asked whether these Zola
fluidus and sensitized cells still
suffer from DNA damage and once again we
made use of our Delta wrecking mutant
and we saw that when cells lacked reggae
survival of these cells decreased by
about five orders of magnitude compared
with their wild head counterparts when
their sensitized to solar photosyn so
this indicates that these persisters
that survive solely treatment suffer
from DNA damage
and to look at when these persisters may
be recovering and repairing damaged DNA
we may use of an inducible copy of rage
and complemented
um the Delta brachi mutant with this
construct
so with this construct what we're able
to do is to Tinker with the timing of
Rec a expression so either inducing Rec
expression before during or after Zola
fluorescent treatment and so we can look
at when rugged expression may be
required
and so we did this we saw that
regardless of whether racket was induced
throughout the course of Zola photos and
treatment so as you can see in
conditions one and two or whether record
was only expressed during the
post-antibiotic treatment recovery
period as you can see in condition three
survive of the populations were
comparable so this suggests that these
cells really only depended on DNA damage
repair and reggae action as they're
recovering from zoloftus and treatment
so this suggests that maybe there is a
window of opportunity for us to Target
these cells that have survived
for quinolone and in solar fluidusin
treatment to try to reduce the burden of
persisters in the post-antibiotic
treatment recovery period
so to look into this we decided to take
on a proof of concept experiment to see
if we can leverage microbial competition
to try to kill persisters as they
recovering from treatment and this work
was led by DMD PhD student Trish hair
and a former undergraduate student
Hannah Englander and so tradition Hannah
decided to focus on E coli missile which
is a probiotic strain of E coli that is
an active ingredient in a product that's
marketed as metaphor in parts of Europe
and in Canada
so Trish and Hannah took a slower
non-growing population of E coli and
treated with levofloxacin and then they
allowed the persisters to recover in
lysogeny broth either together with a
lab strain of E coli or together with E
coli missile and they monitored the
recovery of these levofloxacin treated
cells over time
and they saw that when E coli initial is
added at a concentration that is about
10 to 100 folds below the density of the
levofloxacin treated cells E coli
missile as you can see in the red curve
of the triangle in the circles
they could suppress the recovery of the
levofloxacin treated cells and reduce
persistence in the culture
so to look at how E coli missile is
doing this we first asked if missile is
acting in a contract dependent or
contract independent manner and so to
address this question we may use a
device that is custom made that we call
the H cell because it looks like an
electrochemical H cell and this would
allow us to culture E coli missile and
the levofox and treat it cells in
separate Chambers as separated by a
filter that would allow small molecules
and nutrients to pass through but not
the cells and we saw that when E coli
and this was cultured with the
levofloxacin treated cells in this
manner nissl was no longer able to
inhibit the recovery and reduce the
burden of the levo persisters so this
suggests that the effects of E coli
missile is depend on either direct cell
cell contact or nissl needs to be in
close proximity with the levofloxacin
treat it cells for it to exert its
effect and so right now our lab is
trying to understand and elucidate the
molecular basis of these interactions
so I hope I have shown you in today's
talk that we see that persisters that
can survive for quinolone and
topazomerase inhibitor treatments
um when they're in a slower non-growing
State they still suffer from DNA damage
and they need to undergo DNA damage
repair in the post-antibiotic treatment
recovery period to survive
and so we can try to leverage approaches
like like using microbial competition to
reduce the burden of persisters during
this period
we also see that depending on the drug
that is used some of these persisters
may depend on multi-drug efflux pumps to
survive treatment with these antibiotics
as we had seen with delafoxacin and so
understanding the dependence of these
multi-drug deflux pumps we show that we
can inhibit efflux pump action together
with stimulating the metabolism of these
slower non-grown populations of E coli
to sensitize them to a new
non-fluoroquinolone topazomerase
inhibitor called solofotosin
and so I hope I've shown you today that
there are ways for us to leverage what
we learn about the vulnerability and
defenses of these persisters to try to
sensitize them to existing and emerging
antibiotics and so with that I will end
here and I would be happy to take
questions offline thanks again for
tuning in to this webinar